the most interesting case study is
Singapore which has similar levels of
income obviously a lot smaller from a
both geographical population point of
view but is spending under four percent
of its gdp on healthcare has a full
national safety net scores much higher
than we do in almost any measure of care
and delivers very high tech care
Singapore doesn't has a parallel
government and consumer based system but
the consumer base system is genuinely
consumer-based and I think there's offer
some promise there I understand as well
that the first studies of how health
savings accounts with high deductible
insurance policies affect people's
choices of care have proved quite
positive as proved that there's a
reduction in cost a greater sensitivity
to price without give up in some of in
some of the important measures of health
it may be too early to know and there's
a lot of resistance I should point out a
to that working a lot of people who are
employed in the healthcare industry
either as providers or as experts don't
want to see that work of course because
it does put pressure on prices and it
also puts pressure on one of the key
elements of the consensus which is that
all health care is needed
I was very influenced by a book written
by Shannon Brown lake called overtreated
in which she makes an interesting
argument that a substantial amount of
American health care is excessive and
wasteful is some of it for familiar
reasons relating to defensive medicine
liability but a lot of it because
there's a lack of choice in the system
one of the elements she adds and I think
is most interesting it makes the book
really worth thinking about is that we
think of this as a financial waste but
it's also a medical issue there's not a
single procedure in health care not a
single drug not a single test that
doesn't involve some cost to your health
whether it's the low percentage of
disastrous negative side effects that go
with almost every procedure and test you
know or whether it's the regular
exposure to radiation we have now from
all the MRIs and x-rays we get and her
point which i think is interesting is
that and she has a very different
approach by the way to how she would fix
it than i do but i think her basic
findings that there's an enormous amount
of waste in the system and that a lot of
the structural issues make it a wasted
care actual too much excess of care is
something that's going to have to be
addressed by anything that's adopted
that hopes to not again not just address
pricing but also address quality there
is repair real resistance to that
concept that some healthcare may be
negative and I think we all know from
our own lives that some health care is
is negative there are some some pills we
think to ourselves I'm not sure that's
really worth it there are some tests we
think all right if I took that test and
found out I have a greater propensity to
something nothing changes so why am I
exposing myself to the x-rays and having
the test and I think there's a there's a
question of how these HSAs combined with
high deductible policies may get at that
I actually the author of the book would
disagree they help but there may be some
evidence that